i think originally the drive was from  just crippling insecurity and needing  approval got immediate feedback that was  positive and then i was conditioned to  continue those actions i continued to do  them without the original catalyst that  got them going to begin with i don't  think i suffer you know from  insecurities as much as i used to and it  might just be because i have this  massive big pile of money that i can use  as an emotional crutch to why i'm not  abusive i have come to accept that i  love working and i don't need to judge  myself for that or take in other  people's judgment on how much i should  quote do like this is my life and this  is what i like doing and their ideals  that they've arbitrarily made up as what  they define as balance are irrelevant to  me